as a candidate I promised that I would
end this war and that is what I'm doing
as president and in Afghanistan we're
increasing our troops but make no
mistake this war is ending and all of
our troops are coming home I support the
last administration's efforts to create
the financial rescue program and if
there's one thing that has unified
Democrats and Republicans and everybody
in between is that we all hate at the
bank bailout families across the country
are tightening their belts and making
tough decisions the federal government
should do the same tonight I'm proposing
that we take 30 billion dollars of the
money Wall Street banks have repaid and
use it to help community banks give
small businesses the credit they need to
stay afloat like any cash-strapped
family we will work within a budget to
invest in what we need and sacrifice
what we don't I urge the Senate to
follow the house and pass a bill that
will revitalize our community colleges
and give families a $10,000 tax credit
for four years of college and increased
Pell grants
that's the leadership we are providing
no wonder there's so much cynicism out
there no wonder there's so much
disappointment I have never been more
hopeful about America's future than I am
tonight
let's seize this moment to carry the
dream